hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the inevitable questions for any
ethics of virtue if it's going to be
coherent is what we can call the
priority or indeed if there's only one
the primacy of the virtues or virtue
which among the virtues matters the most
which determines the others making them
virtuous when we run into conflicts
should one of them give way to the other
now here
Cicero is actually staking out a
position that he's arguing is is really
you know representing stoic ethics but
is in some respects a departure from it
the Stoics tended to say that listen all
the virtues are virtue and you know we
don't really pick and choose which one
of them is the most important Cicero
himself has a strong preference for the
virtue and the duties associated with
justice in part because of his
prioritization of the practical or
active life over the theoretical or
contemplative life which is a again a
reversal as well that said towards the
end of book one of on virtues Cicero has
an extended discussion of the priority
of justice over at least two of the
other virtues and he makes some
interesting arguments that we should
look at very carefully the issue of
course is of conflicts arising and you
might say well how could conflicts arise
between virtues aren't they good you
know good things are not going to
conflict with each other
you know the Stoics are all about
rationality it's not rational to pick
four virtues that are actually not going
to be on the same page and Cicero is not
saying that that one of the virtues is
bad
and one of them is good he's saying in
our lives we run into situations where
it's not the virtues themselves that are
coming into conflict but rather the
duties which stem from those virtues
there are duties that stem from wisdom
there are duties that stem from justice
there are duties that stem from courage
that's that's why this book is called on
duties and at times they can be in
conflict with each other in this way we
have to determine which of two goods is
the better good and follow that we don't
do something bad by not realizing the
higher good necessarily well there's
less goodness if we do so so how does he
deal with this he treats three virtues
because there's only four cardinal
virtues for the Stoics we have justice
versus wisdom he devotes the bulk of his
discussion to that justice versus
temperance he doesn't actually say that
justice Trump's temperance and then
justice versus courage which really just
gets a sentence in part because he's
already treated this earlier in book one
so let's look at these arguments he
makes several different arguments in
this passage and some of these are you
know better arguments than others you
may not actually buy into them but we
should at least look at what the
arguments are so Cicero begins by saying
my view is that those duties are closer
to nature which is the stoic you know
sort of criterion what is actually in
accordance with our nature those duties
are closer to nature which depend upon
the social instinct is how it is being
translated here communitas is the Latin
for community and that is the drive or
the impulse that that gives us the
virtue of justice as sister has
explained at great length so he says
those which depend upon the social
instinct are closer to nature than those
which depend up
knowledge those which stem from wisdom
he's not saying that wisdom is not a
great thing but he is saying that
somehow even for us the rational animal
justice and its duties are in some sense
more important so what are the arguments
that he gets the first one that he says
is suppose that a wise man has a life
that with an abundance of everything
pouring in on him he might in perfect
peace study ponder over everything worth
knowing he says if the solitude was
complete if he never saw another human
being that would actually not be a good
of as good of a life he says he would
die so the wise in some sense need
others they require some sort of human
contact is this a good argument it's not
a particularly good argument for justice
on its face but if you say that listen
the duties of justice govern that way in
which we live with others that's
plausible the second argument is much
more interesting here he actually
concedes that wisdom has to do with the
highest things which include the
relations between human beings and the
relations between God's and human beings
so he says that wisdom which I have
given the foremost place is the
knowledge of things human and divine so
it seems like it would be purely
contemplative then he says it's
concerned also with the bonds of union
the connections the relations between
gods and men and the relations of man to
men so here's where that the trick is
and and some people have said this is a
very bad argument but it's actually an
interesting argument if wisdom is the
most important of the virtues as it
certainly is he says so he's giving a
priority to wisdom it necessarily
follows that the duty which is connected
with the social obligation is the most
important duty so he's using the very
priority of wisdom
and the fact that wisdom extends to
these relations between human beings and
relations of human beings to the to the
divine to say that well what is the
virtue that actually governs those
relations justice so that shows that
justice is in some respect although he's
just said wisdom is the most important
virtue and that in some respect wisdom
becomes the it justice becomes the most
important virtue because of wisdoms you
know having this content which only
justice can properly regulate so that's
an interesting argument as well you
might not buy that one the other
arguments that he provides are a little
bit easier to wrap our heads around he
says that service is better than mere
theoretical knowledge the study and
knowledge of the universe would somehow
be lame and defective if no practical
results were to follow here he's staking
out once again the priority of the
practical over the merely theoretical
the active life over the contemplative
life and he says these results are best
seen in safeguarding human in interests
so he says it's essential to human
society so justice ought to be ranked
above speculative knowledge and he says
there's the fourth argument even the
best people show this by their conduct
wise people who you know would be the
you know theoreticians the scientist the
people just staying in their study and
doing their thing when they're called
upon by their country to preserve it to
preserve the social bond or when social
order is breaking down they answer the
call Cicero himself represents this
quite well in his own life but you could
think of many other people like the the
Greek you know engineer Archimedes who
when Syracuse is being attacked turns
his great understanding of natural
phenomena into creating weapons to
protect his city so that's an
interesting argument as
he does consider one possible objection
he says scholars whose whole life and
interests have been devoted to the to
the pursuit of knowledge
they haven't failed to contribute to the
advantages and blessings of mankind
they've trained many to be better
citizens and to render service to their
country and he gives several examples
with Plato you know by the Pythagorean
Lysias and he talks about himself in
that respect as well so in in that
respect justice does have a priority
over wisdom does that mean that we
shouldn't cultivate both of them no you
actually need both of them and in fact
you do need practical wisdom to help
guide you in what justice requires but
developing that disposition of justice
coming from the social instinct
communitas is going to be of prime
importance let's talk about temperance
now this is interesting because Cicero
says justice does have a priority over
the other virtues but not temperance now
why not temperance or moderation right
the one argument that he actually gives
here has to do with what we could call
very hard cases he says there we go
there are some acts either so repulsive
or so wicked Veda or Flagg et Ossa that
even to save one's country to preserve
the the Commonwealth to preserve the
social order a wise person won't commit
them there's some things that justice
says no no no you cannot read a
moderation says you cannot do that you
should not subject yourself or more
perhaps seduce another into that even to
save your own country that is he provide
us examples no he doesn't have provides
examples and it's a little bit comical
why not
he says post
who's a very important stoic thinker has
made a large collection of them but some
of them are so shocking so indecent it
seems immoral even to mention them so he
doesn't provide us with any concrete
examples of what this would include or
encompass but the argument here is that
there are certain things that go against
temperance moderation decency that a
person will not commit even to save
their society again is that a great
argument perhaps not justice versus
courage this one is very straightforward
Cicero deals with this in one line as I
mentioned he talks about this earlier in
on duties in discussing courage courage
lacking justice but also lacking wisdom
is not really courage it's just a kind
of wildness or as he's gonna call it
translated here brutality and savagery
right and in Latin Theory toss wildness
and Imani toss right so without the
governance of justice guiding it then
courage turns into a bad thing so the
duties of justice are going to trump the
duties of courage or there at least
they're going to supervene upon them and
guide them now this is a discussion sort
of wrapping up book 1 Cicero is is
clearly saying where he stands on this
there are four cardinal virtues and for
him although wisdom is in some respects
the best of them justice turns out to be
the most important and the most
determinative of these virtues
you